Back then, it was you traveled
when you performed-- you played
in the direction you moved.
Now we try to put
our instruments
towards the audience
at all times.
Back then, it was very
more militaristic.
There was a formality
to the movement, which
was also very cool and very
hip and it's still done.
It's what they call
the chair step.
They practice that by
stepping as high as a chair.
And so it doesn't translate
to playing an instrument very
well, because you're
bumping around,
but if you have enough
numbers it kind of works out
by the time the sound gets out.
So we move more dance like now.
The uniforms also had a
militaristic kind of nature
to them.
Our uniforms today
still have that line--
that very rigid kind of V line--
that strong, strong shoulders.
But it's definitely
more angles and lines
and artistic visible
visual things.
So the goal is still the same--
to be the best marching band
in the country and do innovative
things, creative things,
high value entertainment
things for the crowd.
One of the things that I think
helped me coming from Disney
is appreciating the value
of a quality performance,
but also creating an
experience for people
that come to the campus.
We want them to have
a game day experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]